I especially want to thank those people
in the audience because even though
they're trying to interrupt the talk
they are showing a lot of Bravery for
even coming into this Auditorium with
such an allegedly genocidal Maniac I
think it's very impressive hold on what
what are you saying I can't quite make
out what you're saying what is that
oh okay now I got it okay
trans lives matter okay I think I got it
I think do you have anything else to say
just that okay does anyone have a pen so
I can write that down
oh that's a naughty word you know that's
that's not a word fit for a lady that's
not the way ladies should speak and I
know we're gonna be talking about how
ladies should speak here tonight
all right good night